what is the biggest misconception or the
biggest thing that people think an
investor or writer director thinks that
they can scale back the budget on but in
reality they can and you have to kind of
let them know anyone who wants to always
say okay if you're going to do well in
this day and age for the technology a
lot of people have to do things on a low
budget scale I know whether it's ultra
low budget or a low budget you know two
different categories it's like if you
have if you have kids if you have
animals if you have stunts those are
things you cannot scale back on you've
got to have a studio teacher there if
you have kids it's going to work or
something about an hour so it's going to
shorten your day if you have animals you
get a higher animal trainer unless it's
a dog that's already trained if you have
stunts you know stunt guys would come
out but it's a minimum four sacks dumps
and you know stunt guys aren't going to
you know work for below something
especially there will be set on fire or
whatnot so I mean there's always a way
around certain things and people would
do it but again you're jeopardizing the
quality of people you're bringing on
board so always I think a lot of people
they make a scrip and go we want to make
it for this versus let's say write a
script that matches your budget don't
write a scrip and go was we can make it
work for this much money anyway know if
you write a script that is a
five-million-dollar script and you're in
you only have five hundred thousand not
go work so you need to scale that script
down and make it work for the budget
that you have so I think that's a common
mistake a lot of people make is they
don't make the bud the scrip match the
budget they actually have then
conversely what do you think people
spend too much money on but really they
could scale back on is it location
thinking they need some amazing place
but really you're just going to see a
little bit of it yeah develop I mean in
la is different because this everyone is
very familiar without family works on
here so you can get lucky and get some
great deals on locations but a lot lots
of times it's you know people are
charging you a lot of money you know in
Utah we got locations for free here for
like a thousand bucks wow you know which
is really hard to do here we've done it
but it knows personal favors but I mean
I don't know it's I think a lot of
people when I spy about the same amount
of money and when there's your hard
costs of like money you're going to spin
regardless know your crew the bigger
mistake is people over pay people when
they don't have the budget for it that's
the biggest thing it's really just being
mismanaged because you can you know from
if we jump on a you know a
two-million-dollar movie you know the
crew is going to be paid three four
hours a day plus the overtime you know
if you're doing a five hundred thousand
dollar movie people working for 150-200
all today you know so but I think a lot
of people just miss manage that and they
go oh well it's this much we know five
hundred thousand dollars and we're going
to still pay them for her at all today
the thing is just they overpay people I
think that's the biggest thing they're
not they're not aware or they try to
take care of their friends or they you
know they don't they do so manager right
so let's suppose they do find a cheaper
location in Utah or some other state
then what are they weighing in terms of
the cost to bring people in or should we
tire higher excuse me local talent like
what what are some of them the questions
that you ask if you have an la-based
production but I decided to take it to
another state to that's cheaper what are
you looking at to make sure that it all
balances out that you're not spending
the same we're comparing the
the cost to crew putting them up in a
hotel their travel pay their per diem
rate for the show and we're weighing
that against how much we were spent on
locations okay and so you kind of tally
it all up and whichever comes out less
is the better option kind of thing oh
yeah yeah so for the two hallmark movies
we did the it was it worked out the
better to do it in Utah it still is
about the same but the setting was right
and we brought two actors in from LA and
then everyone else actor wise for local
hire actors you know so that kind of
helped with the budget as well and then
I didn't line produced that one but I
was a part of the team the production
team but doing it out of state project
it's just really about the the per diems
and all that versus you know just
keeping it here and if you're going to
spend 25 thousand and locations or tent
outside 30 thousand dollars and
locations here and you can do that for
ten thousand dollars and Utah then it it
makes sense to take care of one day
everybody up there it balances out
because you know the money is still
going to be sent and the money's money
so i have 5 55 million dollars as a
million dollars this depends on where I
put it sure and are you also looking at
tax credits and and targeting those
states first to see if that works then
if it doesn't yes yeah we yeah basically
yeah so a lot of time it will be it
depends on the with the story setting is
so if it's you know it's if it's
evergreens and rolling hills or
mountains the smack will be la you don't
have to go somewhere else to get that
setting Bishop there's a lot of exterior
shoots so then if you are going to apply
for the tax credit um who do you contact
within that state i justa phone
commission okay and then as there like a
waiting is certain states take longer
for certain you know people work yeah
you stay with the tax incentive is a
little different where is like South
Carolina you can go there and those you
know give you check when you arrive in
other states in other states it takes 30
days just it just depends on the state
how they have a start
sure
you